bonjour français que j'ai aimé la vie je
vous remercie mon coude est notre invité
politique ce matin vous êtes député
européen membre des républicains on est
ensemble pendant 20 minutes pour une
interview en partenariat avec la presse
quotidienne régionale représentée par
stéphane bern et de ouest france bonjour
stéphane bonjour bonjour on a beaucoup
de sujets abordés avec vous
françois-xavier bellamy mais d'abord
évidemment la nomination du ministre au
poste de ministre des solidarités de
damien abad et cette polémique qui est
arrivé quelques heures après sa
nomination damien abad qui est accusé de
viol des faits qui auraient lu entre en
2010 et en 2011 des faits qu'il conteste
on précisé le clame son innocence pour
le gouvernement la justice est la seule
à pouvoir et à devoir trancher est-ce
que vous êtes aussi sur cette ligne
emmanuel macron elisabeth bande ont
raison de le maintenir à son poste
dans une démocratie et je pense qu'il
faut qu'on fasse tous très attention à
cette question qui devient cruciale
aujourd'hui il ya un moyen et un seul de
résoudre ce type de conflit c'est la
justice si des faits de cette nature ont
été commis ils sont bien sûr d'une
gravité absolue et ce qui compte c'est
que la justice fasse son travail et
qu'elle condamne s'il y a lieu de
condamner mais si la justice ne condamne
pas il me semble qu'on peut pas se
fonder sur la simple expression d'une
accusation pour pouvoir condamner
médiatiquement et politiquement
quelqu'un et je dis ça en ayant
évidemment la plus grande tristesse pour
le choix qu'a fait damien abad qui a
tout simplement trahi son camp oui je
n'ai pas de raison particulière de le
défendre je crois que nous devons tous
défendre aujourd'hui c'est bien sûr la
justice pour toutes les victimes de viol
d'agression sexuelle et il faut que la
justice puisse faire son travail dans
tous les cas où des femmes ont été
agressées mais ne nous substituons pas
collectivement politiques journalistes
ne nous substituons pas à la justice
parce que sinon nous rentrons dans une
société d'une tout autre nature je crois
que c'est une très grande conquête
encore une fois de nos institutions que
d'avoir construit et si remonte au fond
au tout début de la de la démocratie
dans la grèce antique il ya déjà 25
siècles il faut protéger cela c'est très
important parce que sinon eh bien nous
rentrons la spirale
d'une modalité totalement différente de
résolution des conflits
les élections
non je suis absolument en désaccord avec
cela comme je vous le disais ce qui
compte c'est que la justice se prononce
lorsqu il y à une accusation de viol est
une accusation d'une immense gravité
c'est à la justice de faire ce travail
là et en aucun cas les électeurs ne
peuvent faire ce travail à la place des
juges si damien abad pense pouvoir être
blanchi par des élections il se trompe
totalement et il ne pourra pas se
plaindre du procès politique qui lui
sera demain intenté printemps dernier -
matière les accusations dont on parle
déjà plusieurs années est ce que vos
républicain vous étiez au courant de 2,2
de 7,7 de ses affaires et vous même
personnellement est ce que vous saviez
qu'il y avait que damien abad avait des
problèmes de cette nature à titre
personnel je n'ai jamais entendu parler
de ces deux situations certains ont eu
vent de deux de ces accusations d'autres
d'une réputation qui serait celle de
damir ben moi je confesse l'avoir
découvert dans la presse donc vous
l'avez apprécié calme moi j'ai appris
effectivement par l'article de mediapart
qu'il y avait une accusation de viol
portées à l'encontre de damien abad je
n'en avais jamais les questions à votre
connaissance mais non et de fait j'ai
rejoint les républicains en 2019 pour
l'élection européenne ensuite je suis
pas mon mandat plutôt à bruxelles ou à
strasbourg - moins présents à
l'assemblée nationale ou au sénat
j'aurais pu en entendre parler encore
une fois ce qui compte dans ce genre de
situation c'est d'abord que lorsque de
telles accusations sont portées la
justice puisse être saisie alors au delà
de ces 2,7 questions et de ces
accusations qu est ce que vous pensez du
choix de damien abad d'avoir rejoint
gouvernement d d'avoir abandonné son
poste de président du groupe à
l'assemblée de 7 me en retrait de votre
famille politique ce choix est aberrant
et curan il est révoltant par
l'inconstance qui le révèle et par le
discrédit qu'il jette sur la classe
politique tout entière et je pensais on
est dans un moment assez préoccupant de
notre vie politique dans un moment de
confusion
généralisée qui n'est créé que par le
comportement de quelques-uns mais qui a
des effets délétères sur la vie
politique tout entière dans l'ancien
monde qu'on a beaucoup critiqué dans
l'ancien monde on n'aurait pas changer
de couleur politique à la veille d'une
élection parce que le camp d'en face
avaient gagné dans l'ancien monde un
candidat socialiste ne serait pas devenu
de droite parce que la droite était au
pouvoir un candidat de droite ne serait
pas devenu socialiste on a fumé qu'il
fallait qu'il y ait une majorité et
qu'il fallait qu'il y ait une opposition
et je pense c'est très important de
rappeler que si le maquereau niçois avec
cette idée du en même temps a autorisé
une espèce de porosité qui fait
qu'aujourd'hui pendant la composition du
gouvernement imaginé vous on s'est
demandé si catherine vautrin venu de la
droite où il y avait deux bornes venu de
la gauche allait être premier ministre
des personnalités qui nous argue rien en
commun aujourd'hui ce clivage droite
gauche ce qui est pertinent absolument
pertinents c'est la réalité du
pluralisme démocratique et le clivage
droite gauche il a certainement été
épuisés de l'intérieur par le fait que
les grands partis les partis
traditionnels n'ont pas fait le travail
intellectuel nécessaire pour pouvoir
faire vivre le débat démocratique et
être à la hauteur des enjeux et des
conversations qui sont nécessaires pour
l'avenir de notre pays ça n'enlève rien
à la nécessité de ce pluralisme et
surtout ça n'enlève rien à la nécessité
de la clarté de la constance de la
cohérence que les élus doivent avoir
envers les électeurs quand on a critiqué
comme damien abad l'a fait pendant des
années quand on a critiqué avec raison
je pense l'action des manuels mâcon on
n'a pas le droit parce qu'un poste
ministériel passe d'un coup à votre
portée de retourner sa veste et
d'abandonner tout ce qu'on avait dit et
je dis ça ça vaut pour les élus mais
finalement ils ont pas été si nombreux
que ça a tourné casaque ça vaut aussi
pour les électeurs c'est très important
je crois dans cette période de confusion
dans cette période de relativisme absolu
c'est très important de rappeler que la
politique ça a un sens qu' il faut
appuyer son jugement sur des faits qu'on
n'a pas le droit d'ignorer aujourd'hui
le bilan du président de la république
qu'on n'a pas le droit de fermer les
yeux sur ce qu'il compte faire dans les
années qui viennent la composition de
soucoupe de son gouvernement le montre
assez et si on a dans le passé voter à
droite voté au centre droit si on a
défendu dans son comportement des
lecteurs des principes qui sont très
claires on ne peut pas ne pas voir que
le bilan des manuels macron est aux
antipodes
leur ont pas donné aussi des raisons
bien sûr encore une fois les partis
politiques traditionnels ont évidemment
leurs responsabilités elle est immense
dans la crise qu'il traverse aujourd'hui
et la droite va devoir faire un effort
absolument majeur pour se reconstruire
et mérité de nouveau la confiance des
électeurs mais en attendant moi je suis
très frappé je vous le dis très
simplement il arrive souvent que les
électeurs engueuler les élus et ils ont
bien raison de le faire mais il arrive
aussi parfois qu'on puisse être un peu
étonné de voir comme je l'entends
parfois aujourd'hui en allant sur le
terrain soutenir des candidats aux
législatives
des gens qui me disent finalement je
suis de droite mais mâcon c'est pas si
mal que ça je vois pas comment on peut
dire ça quand on est de droite c'est que
on s'inquiète généralement pour la
gestion des finances publiques la dette
de l'état a plus augmenté avant même
l'apparition du coc vide sous emmanuel
macron que sous françois hollande met à
tomber de trois ans suivant quand on est
de droite on veut relancer l'économie il
suffit pas de nommer un ministre de
l'économie qui viennent de la droite
pour ça ça c'est la politique des
revenus de macron c'est la politique du
casting de l'apparence et de la
communication la réalité maintenant les
faits c'est que cette relance de
l'économie et de l'industrie c'est un
échec absolu la france a fait l'année
dernière le plus fort déficit commercial
de son histoire
si on est de droite on peut pas se
satisfaire d'un bilan comme celui-là et
emmanuel macron ça fait pas quelques
mois ça fait même pas quelques années ça
fait dix ans en réalité qu'il est
aujourd'hui à l'elysée c'est ça le bilan
dont six les comptables aujourd'hui on
n'a pas le droit d'être sévère envers le
bilan de la droite et de fermer les yeux
sur le passif du président de la
république et puis je rajoute un dernier
élément parce que il ya la question de
l'économie mais quand on parle de la
droite on parle de la transmission non
pas seulement
de ces valeurs matérielles mais aussi de
quelque chose d'immatériel de la
transmission d'une culture de la
transmission de l'identité de la france
est de ce point de vue là la nomination
du ministre de l'éducation nationale
j'espère ouvrira les yeux à tous les
électeurs qui ont cru trouver en
emmanuel macron un président qui pouvait
finalement correspondre à la droite
classique emmanuel macron est en train
de nommer un ministre de l'éducation
nationale que même jean luc mélenchon
même jean-luc mélenchon s'en suis
convaincu n'aurait pas osé mettre à la
tête du ministère de l'éducation
nationale l'un des cofondateurs du cran
qui défend depuis des années cette
vision des colonials qui consiste à
expliquer que la france est coupable je
cite le ministre de racisme structurel
est ce qu'on a le droit de confier la
plus grande institution de la république
française à quelqu'un qui considère que
la france est coupable de racisme
structurel
ce n'est pas la même chose de dire qu'il
ya du racisme en france et qu'il faut
lutter contre les discriminations et de
dire que la france est structurellement
susceptible
soupçonnable coupable de reproduire des
discriminations et moi je le dis comme
un ancien professeur de philosophie je
suis révolté révolté qu'aujourd'hui le
ministère de l'éducation nationale qui
devraient être confiées à quelqu'un qui
reconstruit l'école comme le lieu d'une
transmission d'une culture ouverte est
donné à tous pour reconstruire la
communauté nationale que ce ministère
qui est crucial pour notre avenir et qui
est aujourd'hui dans une crise majeure
soit confiée à quelqu'un qui au
contraire porte le soupçon sur nos
institutions depuis des années
maintenant je pense qu'encore une fois
on peut écouter le discours du pape
ndiaye on peut respecter sa cohérence
intellectuelle on ne peut pas quand on
vient de la droite approuvé le choix des
manuels macron qui met en danger notre
avenir parce que ce choix là est lourd
de conséquences mais comment vous
l'expliquez ce choix vous parlez de tout
à l'heure de deux politiques du casting
de l'apparence de la communication on a
entre enfin avec avec la nomination de
pap ndiaye on n'est plus dans la
politique dure en même temps mais du
grand écart comment comment est-ce que
vous expliquer le choix de personnalités
aussi différentes au sein du vin d'un
même gouvernement j'ai calculé je ne
peux même pas l'expliquer je ne peux
même pas expliquer ce choix n'a aucun
sens emmanuel macron joue des
institutions absolument décisive sans
aucune espèce de cohérence j'ai critiqué
vivement et je crois qu'il fallait le
faire les réformes menées par jean
michel blanquer au cours des cinq
dernières années une volonté lasker
complète parce que la réforme mais parce
que la réforme du lycée de la région
coeur la réforme du lycée c'était la
continuation de la réforme du collège
mené par najat vallaud belkacem c'était
toujours moins de transmission des
savoirs fondamentaux c'était la
fragilisation du tronc commun on le voit
avec les mathématiques aujourd'hui bien
sûr ça c'était fini finalement la
fragilisation aussi du travail des
enseignants et on le voit dans
l'effondrement de la participation aux
concours de l'enseignement cette année
malgré tout jean michel blanquer et je
lui ai toujours dit je les dis même sur
votre plateau il ya quelques mois avait
un courage que personne ne peut lui
contester qui est qu'il avait affronté
avec force les discours qui précisément
jette le soupçon sur la mission de
l'école au fond ce discours-là très
dangereux qui consiste à dire et nous
l'entendons depuis longtemps ce discours
c'est pas comme si on le découvrait
aujourd'hui que l'école est un lieu de
reproduction des ségrégations que
l'école est un lieu qui sert à justifier
l'échec des noirs et la réussite des
blancs disons le comme ça ce discours-là
chi minh de l'intérieur le projet
universaliste de l'école de la
république ce discours là jean michel
blanquer elle avait combattu avec force
et il a eu raison de le faire et bien
aujourd'hui je ne comprends pas pour
répondre à votre question je ne
comprends pas comment emmanuel macron
qui a nommé jean michel blanquer qu'il a
maintenue pendant cinq ans qui l'a
soutenu dans le discours courageux qu'il
tenait et c'est le point que je lui
reconnais à l'issue de ce quinquennat
comment il vient saper même ceux qui
restaient à défendre du bilan de jean
michel blanquer en nommant pap ndiaye
c'est à dire son exact contraire au
ministère le désaveu total de c'est un
désaveu total bien sûr cinq dernières a
bien sûr et j'entends aujourd'hui le
président de la république nous dit non
non je n'ai pas changé d'avis je n'ai
pas changé de ligne il enfin la vérité
c'est que pas baigné lui même attaqué
avec virulence le bilan des manuels
macron donc soit emmanuel macron au fond
n'a pas changé d'avis mais dans ce cas
sa duplicité est absolue parce qu'on
ne vois pas comment il aurait pu cacher
sa vision profonde pendant cinq ans en
soutenant jean michel blanquer à
l'éducation nationale soit soit c'est
que jean michel c'est que c'est que
manuel macron se joue de nous et de
l'école alors jean-michel bancaires
notamment avait un discours très fort
sur la laïcité est ce que vous attendez
à ce que cette chose change au sein de
l'école de l'éducation nationale et
j'espère que non et encore une fois ce
qui compte ce n'est pas seulement la
laïcité comme une espèce de valeurs
abstraites ce qui compte c'est de
refaire de l'école et c'est quand même
la priorité majeure doit faire de
l'école le lieu de la transmission d'une
culture commune j'ai commencé mon
engagement public en publiant les
déshérités nous vivons aujourd'hui dans
une situation de crise de l'école que je
dénonçais il ya déjà presque dix ans
mais qui n'a fait que s'aggraver depuis
une crise de l'école qui fait
qu'aujourd'hui nous avons le système
scolaire le plus inégalitaire de tous
les pays de l' ocde que au fond notre
système permet encore à ceux qui
viennent des familles les plus favorisés
de réussir ça n'est pas d'ailleurs une
question de couleur de peau c'est plutôt
une question effectivement de milieux
sociaux et que de l'autre côté eh bien
ceux qui ne bénéficient pas de ces
conditions de départ ont le plus de
chances d'échouer ce constat là on peut
tous le partage et la grande scission
c'est la grande question c'est comment
on y répond et vous avez des gens qui
comme pape ndiaye explique que c'est le
coeur du travail de l'école d'organiser
cette ségrégation ccsa fondamentalement
moi j'ai lu la condition noire le livre
de ma peine c'est un travail dans lequel
au fond il ramène tout à la couleur de
peau tout est fait pour montrer que
derrière en fait la question de la race
une certaine gauche a retrouvé sa
nostalgie de la lutte des classes et
bien moi je ne crois pas à cette vision
là je pense au contraire que l'école
peut faire réussir tous les enfants
quelle que soit leur couleur de peau à
condition qu'elles deviennent
indifférente à leur couleur de peau à
condition qu'elle leur dise à tout ce
que s'ils travaillent que s'ils sont
prêts à embrasser la culture qui leur
est offerte gratuitement et la france
est quand même rappelons le quand même
un pays qui a le mérite immense d'offrir
gratuitement l'éducation à tous les
enfants qui grandissent sur son sol et
bien si les enfants travaillent si nous
reconstruisons la transmission de la
culture si nous faisons de nous
confiance à notre culture pour faire
grandir des enfants alors ils pourront
réussir et ça finalement c'est d'une
certaine manière l'exact inverse du
discours que tient le nouveau ministre
de l'éducation nationale un dernier mois
je sais d'autant plus grave pardonnez
moi que monsieur ndiaye lui même qui
veut nous expliquer que la condition
noire en france et celle de la minorité
opprimée qu'il décrit en venant des
états unis avec le discours qu'il a
importé du monde américain monsieur pape
ndiaye est lui même un exemple de la
vacuité de sa propre dénonciation parce
que lui même évidemment issu de la
minorité dont il parle lui même enfant
d'une famille modeste a pu devenir
ministre de l'éducation nationale
universitaire normalien avoir accès aux
meilleures études dans notre pays sa
soeur marie ndiaye a reçu le prix
goncourt le prix femina est une très
grande romancière c'est bien la preuve
et c'est cela qu'il faut redire
aujourd'hui que tous les enfants peuvent
réussir à condition de recevoir cette
culture que nous sommes capables de
partager avec l'année si abc dont encore
une fois de nouveaux de transmettre
notre culture et on voit ici que on
retrouve les manuels mâcon qui
expliquait qu'il n'y a pas de culture
française
est ce qu'il ne faut pas laisser faire
ses preuves à l'éducation nationale et
voir ce qu'il va faire en tant que
ministre malgré tout cette nomination
est un message nous verrons ce qu'il va
faire cela n'enlève rien au fait que je
crois à la continuité je pense que les
individus les personnes ont le droit à
leur cohérence et je reconnais
parfaitement le droit de pape ndiaye à
la légitimité de son discours viril
défend un discours qui est parfaitement
clair qui est parfaitement explicite je
trouve cela d'ailleurs pour ma part
infiniment plus respectable que cette
espèce dans même temps et de confusion
généralisée si vous voulez ce qui
m'inquiète n'est pas que pap ndiaye
tiennent ce discours ça fait longtemps
qu'il le tient je l'entends je le lis et
je suis prêt à le combattre parce que
intellectuellement je me sens
radicalement opposées à cette cohérence
intellectuelle ce qui me paraît
extrêmement grave c'est qu'emmanuel
macron en étant aujourd'hui président de
la république dans un contexte de
fracturation déjà très grand de notre de
notre société de notre vie démocratique
soit capable de faire dans ce en même
temps improbable dans ce grand écart que
vous vous dit à l'instant le passage de
jean michel blanquer et de papa papa
niayes et là pour le coup il ya une
incohérence qui ne peut être que
choquant
on va avancer parce qu'on a on a encore
quelques sujets à voir avec vous vous
parlez des pénurie d'enseignants
évidemment qu'ils sont raides ya aussi
des pénurie de soignants aujourd'hui est
ce que vous êtes inquiet sur la
situation de l'hôpital il ya un manque
de soignants il ya un manque de lits ça
laisse craindre un été compliqué dans
les hôpitaux de france est-ce que vous
demander des mesures immédiates au
gouvernement il faut bien sûr des
mesures immédiates et puis il faut
surtout enfin des réformes structurelles
de long terme pour sauver notre hôpital
parce que l'hôpital est aujourd'hui en
situation d'agonie vous avez aujourd'hui
en france un service d'urgence sur six
qui est obligé de fermer faute de
soignants vous avez un chu sur deux dans
les urgences sont obligés de fermer ce
qui veut dire que aujourd'hui dans notre
pays beaucoup de nos concitoyens ne
pourront plus aller potentiellement se
faire soigner en urgence parce que leurs
services d'urgence sera fermée ou alors
devant aller beaucoup plus loin ce qui
évidemment à moyen terme va coûter en
qualité de soins et ce qui pourrait même
coûter des vies humaines donc on est
devant une situation vous l'avez dit
d'urgence absolue mais au fond cette
urgence c'est d'abord l'urgence d'un
travail de long terme pour reconstruire
notre système de santé
malheureusement on le voit le bilan du
dernier quinquennat là aussi sur ce
point y compris avec l' alerte qui a été
la crise du grenelle virus est
absolument accablant et malgré le
secteur de la santé ce n'est pas
suffisant et le ségur de la santé est
manifestement insuffisant au fond on est
finalement devant l'hôpital comme devant
l'éducation nationale on est au coeur de
la crise de l'état qui dans ses missions
régaliennes et empêché de faire son
travail par la paupérisation des moyens
qui lui sont confiées prenez la mission
d'enseignement il ya plus de soignants
il ya plus d'enseignants on est en train
de passer aujourd'hui les concours de
l'enseignement en mathématiques vous
aviez vous aviez 800 candidats pour 1000
postes ça veut dire que quand vous êtes
candidat en réalité a priori vous êtes
recruté d'ailleurs le concours et elle
est professeur de mathématiques l'ont
constaté le concours était fait pour
pouvoir écarter le moins de candidats
possibles on se trouve devant une
pénurie d'enseignants et pourquoi parce
que en 1981 vous commenciez une carrière
d'enseignant avec 2,3 smic en moyenne
aujourd'hui 1 bill de smic et donc la
paupérisation des soignants la
paupérisation des enseignants de tous
ceux qui servent la vie qui font grandir
la vie qui préserve la vie c'est au fond
la fragilisation de notre état lui-même
qui qui qui qui doit nous appelé à une
réforme de profondeur autre sujet qui
est évoqué comme une priorité de ce
nouveau gouvernement c'est le pouvoir
d'achat le il ya eu l'annoncé a été
faite hier qu'un projet de loi serait
présenté au conseil des ministres avant
les législatives
est ce que c'est un bon timing et qu'est
ce que vous attendez de ce genre de
projet de loi eh bien j'espère que ce
projet de loi apportera autre chose que
des mesures démagogiques de nouvelles
aides publiques 2 milliards il ya
quelques timbres législatif pour vous le
fait d'annoncer son projet de loi si
rapidement ou sait vraiment où liée à l'
urgence du moment il ya une urgence sur
la question du pouvoir d'achat mais
cette urgence je crois qu'elle se trouve
non pas dans le fait et ça pour le coup
ce serait de la démagogie électoraliste
non pas dans le fait de distribuer des
primes opportunément les primes macron
qui sont comme une espèce de moyens pour
le président de la république de se
faire valoir en distribuant notre argent
parce que c'est de cela qu'il s'agit non
le vrai sujet c'est que l'état enfin
face les réformes courageuses dont il a
besoin pour faire baisser la pression
fiscale pour faire baisser la pression
sur les salaires pour faire baisser les
charges qui pèsent sur le travail
aujourd'hui en france quand on travaille
on touche trop peu d'argent les français
sont finalement victime d'une situation
de de pressions fiscales et sociales sur
le travail
production ont baissé dans la dernière
partie du quinquennat il faut encore
aller plus loin il faut maintenant faire
baisser les charges qui pèsent sur le
travail et pour le faire de manière
cohérente et courageuse il faut mettre
en face de ces baisses de charge les
économies qui sont indispensables parce
que si on ne fait que baisser la
fiscalité et bien sans faire d'économie
on ne fait qu'augmenter la dette et
c'est ce qui est en train aujourd'hui de
se produire avec la remontée de
l'inflation et la remontée des taux
notre pays se trouve aujourd'hui dans
une situation incroyablement funeral
france examinerait terminer sur la
situation de votre parti en campagne
évidemment pour les législatives il ya
un conseil stratégique aujourd'hui dans
votre parti est ce que la stratégie
l'indépendance et la bonne eau est ce
qu'il faut la revoir la stratégie
d'indépendance et évidemment la bonne je
veux dire par là que comme je le disais
tout à l'heure il est absolument hors de
question pour une droite qui tient à ce
qu'elle a toujours défendu de se mettre
derrière emmanuel macron sur aucun plan
j'ai tenté de le dire dans un texte qui
paraît aujourd'hui dans le figaro mais
sur aucun plan je crois que nous pouvons
nous reconnaître dans ce bilan et je ne
dis pas ça pour la facilité de
l'opposition moi aussi j'aimerais bien
être du côté de la majorité c'est
tellement plus confortable et c'est tout
à fait normal moi aussi j'aimerais bien
pouvoir me dire que je m'entends bien
avec le président de la république le
gouvernement toutes les autorités de
l'état non je crois que nous avons
aujourd'hui un devoir de lucidité
évidemment c'est pénible évidemment
c'est douloureux de se dire que nous
sommes obligés de répéter toujours le
constat d'une situation de crise mais
nous n'avons pas le droit de ne pas
ouvrir les yeux parce que la vérité
c'est on parlait la remontée des taux
d'intérêt que dans quelques semaines
dans quelques mois parce que les
réformes n'ont pas été faites nous
allons nous trouver dans une situation
de tension très forte sur le plan
budgétaire et donc sur le plan
économique et social et dans ces moments
de tension il faudra que le président de
la république et il aura une majorité je
crois mais il faudra qu'il est surtout
une opposition une opposition crédible
sérieuse courageuse capable d'offrir une
alternative aux français alors vous
garder un espoir très clair sur la ligne
avec emmanuel macron et de l'autre côté
eric zemmour examen mais aussi l'appel à
une ondée à l'union des droites lui
l'appel à l'union des droites ils vont
tend la main est ce que ça toi entendu
il faut l'accepter ou pas je ne vois pas
que la main soit vraiment tendu puisque
eric zemmour est engagé dans la campagne
législative avec des candidats dans
toutes les circonscriptions et se
présente du marché libre la présidence
les républicains comme annoncé c'est une
très bonne chose que de toute façon nous
notre famille politique nous avons
commencé à travailler sur les
initiatives depuis des mois maintenant
nous avons nos idées nous avons notre
cap nous tenons notre ligne c'est une
bonne chose d'aller devant les électeurs
et les électeurs trancheront et puis
nous nous avons devant nous je crois et
c'est le plus important la tâche de
reconstruire une famille politique qui
puisse de nouveau susciter la confiance
des français moi j'ai toujours pensé et
je continue de dire que c'est au sein
des républicains que cette
reconstruction se fera parce que les
républicains ont cette responsabilité
que leur confère l'histoire et je crois
aux temps longs d'être la famille
politique qui représente les électeurs
la vraie question c'est encore une forme
je crois qu'on a toujours pris le
problème à l'envers la vraie question
c'est comment notre famille politique
peut-elle de nouveau susciter la
confiance de tous les électeurs qui
attendent que la droite dans ce pays les
représentent et c'est la question qui
nous attend c'est le travail que nous
avons à faire sur nous même c'est pas
des logiques d'appareil des manoeuvres
d'appareil qui vont changer quoi que ce
soit à la situation que nous traversons
aujourd'hui c'est d'abord un travail
intellectuel de clarté c'est aussi un
travail moral de constance et de
cohérence qui s'est trop lent à l'est
mais la confiance des électeurs est ce
que cette relance des républicains est
possible en cas de nouvelle défaite
électorale cuisante aux législatives qui
s'imposent mais je crois qu'elle est
nécessaire la question n'est même pas de
savoir si elle est possible et même si
vous vous retrouvez avec un nouvel échec
et un groupe rabougri à la structure
nous savons très bien que nous sommes
dans une situation difficile que nous
vivons ces élections dans un contexte
extrêmement compliqué à cause du
résultat de l'élection présidentielle on
va évidemment pas se mentir mais ça
n'empêche pas à s'engager à fond dans la
campagne législative
je suis comme beaucoup de mes collègues
je suis sur le terrain pour soutenir des
candidats aux législatives
de trois à quatre fois par semaine je
continuerai de le faire au cours des
semaines qui viendront et moi ce que je
peux vous dire c'est que sur le terrain
la réalité est quand même aujourd'hui
encore très ouverte parce que je crois
que les électeurs savent très bien qu
emmanuel macron a bien sûr été élu dans
l'élection présidentielle mais que le
vrai sujet maintenant c'est celui des
équilibres qui vont se dessiner dans
l'élection législative et qu' ils ont
devant eux la nécessité d'exprimer dans
l'élection qui vient le préférence pour
l'avenir de leur pays on n'a pas besoin
d' abdiquer l'élection législative au
nom de l'élection présidentielle il ya
bien sûr un scrutin dont il faut prendre
acte mais il y en a un autre devant nous
et ce scrutin qui se joue il doit être
pour les français et pour les électeurs
de droite en particulier y compris ceux
qui dans cette élection peut être votée
par défaut en se disant qu'il fallait
éviter le moins pire il ya dans cette
élection législative l'occasion
d'exprimer leurs attentes et leurs
inquiétudes et quand on regarde la
composition du gouvernement des
inquiétudes on a bien des raisons de
s'en faire un dernier mot
françois-xavier ami christian jacob va
quitter la tête du parti après les
législatives elle a annoncé vous êtes
candidat à sa succession on verra qui
seront les candidats à cette élection
interne je pense est une étape après
l'autre ce qui compte pour nous
maintenant c'est l'élection législative
c'est vraiment le plus important et puis
la reconstruction pas trois parties moi
je veux contribuer à cette refondation
intellectuelle je veux contribuer à ce
travail de reconstruction dont nous
avons tellement besoin et encore une
fois je ne veux pas le faire pour la
droite je ne suis pas un homme de parti
ce qui compte pour nous d'abord ça n'est
pas de servir les intérêts d'une
étiquette ce qui compte c'est d'abord de
reconstruire le débat démocratique en
france et le débat démocratique en forme
et vous dit la
présidente je jouerai tout mon rôle on
verra encore une fois qui sera candidat
à cette élection mais mais je ne serai
pas passifs et je ne resterai pas en
dehors de ce travail absolument décisif
qui s'engage merci beaucoup merci france
était notre invité ce matin la une
d'ouest france on en parlait
sous-effectif à l'hôpital l'été
s'annonce tendu c'est à la une de votre
journal stéphane merci beaucoup
[Musique]